>> I think it's going to take a few decades
for India to become a
superpower.
We -- unless we solve the basic problems of
our poverty, the
infrastructure, and plying our own people
to create wealth, it's not
going to be easy.
For decades, we have forced our people to
either not be proud of what
they are doing or to take their money out
of the country.
It's only in the last one decade of reforms,
or a little more than
that, that the reforms have taken place.
But these are not enough.
We have miles and miles to go and I do not
see any kind of seriousness
about that.
If we're really, really want to become a superpower,
what we have to do
is unshackle our businesses totally.
We have to allow the global best practices
to come in freely.
We have to allow the ingenuity of our own
people to be -- to help us
create wealth in this country.
The poverty in this country so blinding and
so deep that it will
probably take us at least 2 to 3 decades,
with strong reforms and when
I say reforms, I don't mean the reforms that
we are seeing for now, but
much stronger and much better than that for
India to become a
superpower.
Superpower does not mean only in sense of
military.
[INAUDIBLE] collapsed because it didn't have
the, they didn't actually
care for their own people.
It was just a handful of people on the top
who were controlling the
lives and futures of the whole country.
We as a democracy must [INAUDIBLE] in the
sense that we must, we in
India allowed to economic freedom [INAUDIBLE]
and we must and in an
actual economic freedom, [INAUDIBLE] and for
that, we need to do many
more things in many more ways for India to
be a superpower.